Sam graciously wanted me to accept this
award because I'm the first transgender
woman to win this award Jim patches and
Sam Smith Make History at the 65th
annual Grammy awards ceremony the pair
took home best pop Duo group performance
and their infectious track Unholy making
Kim the first trans woman to win this
award and Sam the first non-binary
person to win this award leading to
withstanding ovation
[Applause]
inner acceptance speech she thanked
Madonna as well as past trans artists
who came before her including the late
Sophie thank you so much for your
inspiration Sophie um I adore you and
your inspiration will forever be in my
music
um Madonna for fighting for lgbtq rights
um so much I don't think I could be here
without Madonna
now just three months earlier Kim also
broke another record being the first
trans woman to score a number one hit on
the Billboard Hot 100 all thanks to her
and Sam's Smash Hit which they also
performed at the Grammys
[Laughter]